politique nous sommes en ligne en direct
avec Gulliver krak Gulliver qui est
notre correspondant à qui est avec qui
nous est ces dernières heures de ces
rumeurs de la présence de Joe Biden donc
confirmé dans la capitale
ukrainienne le président américain donc
qui est en visite surprise bonjour
Gulliver on nous dit que le président
volody mirzeninski a donc rencontré ça y
est Joe Biden est-ce que vous avez des
précisions vous sur cette visite qu'on
ne fait qu'apprendre et qui semble-t-il
à débuter il y a quelques heures
maintenant
oui vous voyez si je suis en sous-sol
c'est parce que les sirènes ont retenti
pour une alerte aérienne à Kiev juste au
moment je pense au Joe Biden était en
train de entrer dans la capitale et ou
peut-être c'était au début de cette
rencontre avec le président volody
meilleur Zelenski je n'ai pas de
précision sur exactement où ils en sont
dans leur pour parler mais il y a déjà
eu je pense une déclaration de jobiden
qui a été publié à savoir que il a
promis de fournir plus d'un munition
pour les systèmes highmers que les
États-Unis ont déjà fourni aux
Ukrainiens c'était déjà allaité dernier
et qui de la vie de beaucoup d'ukrainien
ont été parmi les armes livrées par les
États-Unis qui ont vraiment changé la
donne dans cette guerre parce que ils
ont permis aux Ukrainiens d'effectuer
des frappes de très haute précision
assez longue distance sur des bases et
sur des dépôts de munitions russes en
territoire actuellement
occupé par la Russie en Ukraine les
Ukrainiens depuis un moment déjà réclame
non seulement plus de munitions pour ces
systèmes de lance-roquette mais aussi
des requêtes permettant de tirer un peu
plus loin avec une portée plus loin le
Royaume-Uni avait déjà annoncé que il
livrerait des armes permettant de tirer
plus loin et peut-être que les
Ukrainiens espèrent obtenir quelque
chose de similaire ou une promesse
comparable de la part des États-Unis
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils espèrent aussi
c'est une annonce bien sûr sur les
avions de chasse F-16 mais ça c'est
devenu peut-être une sorte obsession
chez les Ukrainiens ils parlent beaucoup
beaucoup de cela alors que de la vie des
analystes militaires et des soldats sur
le terrain ce dont ils ont besoin
beaucoup beaucoup plus heureux ce sont
des munitions pour toute sorte de
artillerie et de systèmes de requête
parce que il risque d'être à court de
munitions avec dans les semaines qui
viennent en ce moment je vous rappelle
l'Ukraine est en train de défendre dans
l'est du pays contre une tentative en
tout cas de lancer une offensive à
grande envergure par la Russie et puis
de se préparer pour une contre-offensive
crânienne qui est attendue au printemps
pour essayer de reprendre le contrôle de
plus de territoire actuellement occupé
par la Russie merci beaucoup Gulliver
Craig en direct donc de ce sous-solaquet
vous les les alertes aériennes ont donc
été déclenché